spider-man movies have come a long way
since the Sam Raimi days but maybe you
still have a few questions like what is
barf
why was tony stark's such a bad boss and
is mysterio really dead we'll get into
all this and more as we break down the
ending of spider-man far from home over
the course of five movies Iron Man has
been Peters mentor and personal role
model taking over what's traditionally
been the Uncle Ben role as a result this
is another non Iron Man MCU movie that
sure has a lot of Tony Stark this time
around Tony's hogging of the spotlight
is even more impressive since being
fried by the full might of the Infinity
stones that guy is extremely dead and
the world loves him for it with murals
on walls honoring the hero from the
streets of Queens to the canals of
Venice while Tony's left a gigantic
legacy behind for Peter to draw from
Peters having to learn to get by on his
own sort of through the use of
over-the-top technology Stark is still
watching over him instead of building a
suit of armor around the world ala age
of Ultron Tony left gear behind for
Peter
a young man who clearly reminded him of
himself but where Tony didn't realize
his capacity for heroism until well into
adulthood Peter is putting his life on
the line before he's even gone through
the trouble of learning how to drive
it's an earnest desire to help that the
movies villain Jake Gyllenhaal's
Mysterio quickly learns to use against
him in another instance of the movie
leaning on the established MCU far from
home features the return of Tony Stark's
by nearly augmented retro framing
technology or barf God I got to work on
that acronym barf is an absurdly
advanced virtual reality platform that
we've seen previously in Captain America
Civil War in its previous appearance
this tech was mostly used to show off
Tony's home movies much to the
frustration of its inventor Jake
Gyllenhaal's Quentin Beck barf isn't the
only piece of stark tech that Beck is
using to put one over on the world
he's also after the surprisingly
important pair of glasses Tony was
previously seen wearing casually during
the events of infinity war and that he
bequeathed to Peter Parker following his
death either put on these glasses
or started matte trash Tony being Tony
these are no ordinary glasses Beck's
primary reason for wanting the glasses
has to do with their connection to a
powerful fleet of weaponized drones
capable of projecting a massive illusion
in London the glasses are also seemingly
capable of tapping into every device
connected to a computer more or less
instantaneously kind of terrifying power
is this what Tony was doing with those
glasses the whole time spying on
people's phones I know that it's
confusing Tony being Tony the Edythe
name is an acronym for even in death I'm
the hero but by the time Edith is being
used to help Bek attack London with a
combined elemental illusion it feels
more like a fitting name would be even
in death I think I know best and
accidentally put millions of people at
risk no wonder so many of Tony's old
employees hate him
after manipulating Peter into handing
over Edith Mysterio celebrates with his
surprisingly robust staff hilariously
this squad of disgruntled middle
management types is united by one thing
a lousy working relationship with
Anthony Edward Stark one character
William Riva is revealed to have turned
to the dark side under Mysterio because
Jeff Bridges yelled at him during a
tense moment in 2008 iron man he stayed
mad about that encounter for more than
10 years while helping out Mysterio
during his staged encounter with a
molten fire elemental Peter notices a
little bit of strangeness regarding the
physics of the fight with his webs
bouncing off what appear to be some
invisible objects near the under attack
ferris wheel Peter sort of shrugs off
the strangeness at least initially what
really sells Peter on Mysterio's
villainy is MJ's recovery of a projector
drone in the aftermath of the battle
which displays pre-rendered footage of
one of the elementals in action seeing
this footage Peter realizes that the
elementals aren't real and that Mysterio
is not to be trusted after being beaten
by Mysterio and his first confrontation
Peter returns for a second round after
designing itself a new suit in very iron
Manesh fashion Peter's goal during the
final London encounter is to take out
the many drones Beck's deployed to make
his Greg
and avengers level illusion shutting him
down before he can hurt any innocent
civilians or kill Peter and his friends
Peter smashes up the stark drones in a
variety of ways one of the more exciting
of which is his stylish deployment of
electrically charged taser webbing
caused them to explode while this tech
might seem like a new addition to
Peter's upgraded suit they're actually a
holdover from the first suit that Tony
Stark designed the one that sported way
more ways to kill people than Pierre
would realistically need all in all this
final act shows Peter learning to trust
his gut especially his Peter tingle
which comes into play in his final
showdown with Mysterio
it also shows him fully embracing the
trust that Tony had placed in him after
realizing that Tony Stark made plenty of
mistakes throughout his Ironman career
spider-man stops beating himself up for
giving back control of Edith and goes to
work on saving the day and if diving
headfirst into danger to fix horrible
world-threatening mistakes you've made
isn't living up to the legacy of Tony
Stark what is Mysterio meets his end
thanks to spider-man sushi or
persistence with the hero fighting while
physically outnumbered and under
psychological attack by midway through
the battle it's obvious that Peter is
going to win instead of despairing or
running away Mysterio keeps his cool and
begins to make reference to an enigmatic
contingency plan Peter makes his way
closer to Beck wrecking his drones and
using his spider sense to blast through
the illusions that barf tech throws up
he also defends himself against a hail
of bullets that Mysterio fires at him
one of which strikes Mysterio himself
apparently fatally but of course
considering the scale of vex illusions
it's impossible not to wonder if he's
actually a goner there's plenty of
evidence from the comics to make this a
legitimate question not only has Quentin
Beck faked his own death before but
several other criminals have taken on
the identity of Mysterio in Beck's place
in short there's plenty of room for the
master of illusion to make a return one
way or another and either way
unbeknownst to Peter Mysterio's back-up
plan is now in motion after Spidey hulks
the attack one of the people on
Mysterio's payroll can be seen
downloading data onto a portable drive
walking away with unknown intentions
it's implied that what's been copied as
data related to the fight specifically
camera footage from the drones it ends
up coming back in a big way during the
mid credit scene but for all anyone
knows in the hours after the battle
Mysterio has been defeated and the
threat he poses is over unfortunately
poor Peter Parker is far from done with
this fight suffice to say it looks like
this Peter can't even get through high
school with a secret identity intact if
only he had gone into the battle dressed
as night monkey this probably wouldn't
have been such a big deal
the comics once again offers some
precedent for these plot points back in
Mysterio's first appearance an amazing
spider-man number 13 he poses as a crime
fighter and strikes a deal with Jay
jonah Jameson to expose Spidey's
identity to the world and the pages of
The Daily Bugle what we see in the mid
credit scene is a clear reference to
Mysterio's debut before all of that goes
down Peter returns to New York having
finally established a romantic
relationship with MJ that's not the only
relationship on Peters mind though he
also has questions for happy Hogan and
Aunt May regarding their relationship
status in the new post blip World Order
after interrogating his Guardian about
her love life
Peter rolls his eyes and sets off for a
triumphant session of swinging around
the buildings of Manhattan a well-earned
victory lap it's a way different feel
from Peters first adventures in
homecoming which mostly stayed across
the East River in the slightly less
vertical borough of Queens more than any
of Peters other adventures in the MCU so
far this sequence feels like a throwback
to the Sam Raimi spider-man movies which
featured no shortage of exhilarating
manhattan-based web slinging charmingly
Peter doesn't go it alone taking MJ up
into the skies to swing downtown for a
few blocks judging by her excitedly
panicked reaction it's something she'll
have to get used to but despite the
danger she still looks happy to give it
a whirl if the movie ended here it'd be
a happy note unfortunately for Peter the
movie's post-credit scenes have a major
change in store for him one that looks
primed to permanently shake up
spider-man's place in the MCU check out
one of our newest videos right here
even more looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
you